Justin Verlander and a Chocolate Milk
In High School, Justin Verlander, Major League
Baseball star pitcher and recent victim of
a hacker who stole explicit pictures of Verlander
and his girlfriend Kate Upton, traded a small
percentage of his eventual $3.12 million signing
bonus for a 50 cent chocolate milk.
This happened while the future MLB superstar
was in the 10th grade at Goochland High School
in Virginia.
Short 50 cents needed for a chocolate milk
that day, he asked his friend Daniel Hicks
for the money.
“So I said, ‘How about I give you [.001%]
of my pro signing bonus if you give me 50
cents now?’
He found a napkin, wrote it up, and I signed
it.
I forgot about it, but after I signed [with
Detroit], he comes over and whips out this
old napkin.
I’m like, oh my God!
My bonus was 3-point-something million.”
That worked out to a little over $3K for the
industrious Daniel Hicks who turned 50 cents
into $3120 in just about five years when Verlander
signed with Detroit in 2004 out of college
for a guaranteed contract of $4.5 million
(max of $5.6 million) with a signing bonus
of $3.12 million.
This might not have worked out quite so well
for Hicks had Verlander not come down with
strep throat at a key time in High School.
At that time, Verlander was regularly throwing
93 mph, but when scouts were coming to take
a close look at him at the start of the season,
he got sick with Group A Streptococcus (a.k.a.
strep throat) and thereafter his velocity
dropped to around 81 mph for a good portion
of the rest of the season.
By the time he recovered most of his velocity
at the end of the year, the scouts were no
longer around, so he went to college.
Had he signed out of high school, he very
likely wouldn’t have gone nearly so high
in the draft and his signing bonus would have
been significantly less.
In college at Old Dominion University, he
drastically bolstered his value in scout’s
eyes in the three years he attended, setting
a school record for strikeouts in a single
game (17), a single season (139 and then broke
it again at 151), all-time strikeout leader
(427 in 335 innings), and finished with a
2.57 ERA in college.
In 2003, a year before he was drafted, he
also helped the U.S. win a silver medal in
the Pan Am Games.
Ultimately he was drafted second overall in
2004, after Matt Bush.
As you might expect from becoming instantly
wealthy right out of college and since bolstering
that with a seven year $180 million contract,
among other earnings throughout his career,
Verlander does not regret signing the deal
for the chocolate milk.
“Was a chocolate milk worth $3,000?
I want to say yes.
I was parched.”
Bonus Facts:
• Milk is white thanks to a protein called
casein, which makes up about 80% of the proteins
in milk.
Casein scatters and deflects light more or
less uniformly throughout the visual spectrum,
so milk looks white in the human visible spectrum.
• The reason raw milk goes bad so quickly
when left out, at least for drinking purposes,
is that the lactose in milk ends up getting
processed by microorganisms into lactic acid.
Depending on the microorganisms performing
this processing, this can produce a variety
of tasty products, such as various types of
cheeses, yogurts, buttermilk, etc. or create
something quite rancid.
• Verlander was named Rookie of the Year
in 2006.
At the time it happened, he was out washing
his car.
He claims he even forgot what day the announcement
would be made so wasn’t thinking about it.
He came inside half way through washing his
car to find 20 missed calls on his phone from
the Tigers.
As excited as he was finding out about winning,
rather than immediately celebrating, he stated
“I had to go out and finish washing my car—can’t
leave the soap on there.”
• Grade A and Grade B milk are the two varieties
allowed in the United States.
Grade A milk is used for direct consumption.
Grade B milk is used for making cheeses and
other types of milk product.
There is very little difference between the
two; Grade A milk is cooled using refrigeration
(due to the requirement to keep it at 45 F
within two hours of milking) and Grade A milk
farms are inspected every six months.
Grade B milk is typically cooled in cans immersed
in cold flowing water underground (with the
same temperature of 45 F).
Grade B milk farms, though, only need inspected
every two years.
There are also a few differences in terms
of bacterial count and things of this nature,
but this isn’t a significant difference
when factoring in eventual pasteurization
and the like of milk sold to be drunk.